Cory is in Palm Beach hey Cory how are
you I'm okay Dave are you better than I
deserve
how can I help oh my god a question for
you I currently have a student loan
about about forty three forty four
thousand dollars yeah
and I'm in a plan called income driven
plan where I'm a police officer and if I
pay it over a 10-year period they read
off the remaining balance yuck and the
payment and the payments are currently
like 20 bucks a month
yeah how old are you I'm 34 years old
how long you been in that plan I've been
in a plan for last two years okay no I
don't want to stay in debt eight more
years that sucks
who wants to be in debt for eight years
what do you watch your household income
am i helpful and come on that plan no no
that planning I do that I'm talking
about your household income what do you
all make are you married
I am Erica what are you and your wife
make what's your household income $150
dude give Salome her eviction papers
woman out of your house seriously for
I'm not screwing around with 43,000
you're making 160 kill that thing man
don't hurt in the street get your life
back don't be playing footsie with the
government for eight years and hope they
don't change something one thing you
know for sure they're gonna screw the
student loan mess there's 1.3 trillion
dollars in student loan debt and there's
people run around all over the culture
screaming that somehow that the taxpayer
who loaned them as money has done them
wrong I got to tell you man there this
is not gonna go well long term you want
out of student loan debt as fast as you
can possibly get out this political
climate is not gonna allow a lot of
these things to happen the way they've
been happening it's got to stop at some
point so hey thanks for the call we
appreciate you joining us it does have
to stop folks think about it we live in
a culture where we the people you and I
known as taxpayers have allowed our
elected representatives who are
apparently idiots
I mean that's a fair statement we
elected them so what's that make us but
anyway to extend guaranteed loans we are
you and I are co-signers for 18 year
olds to take out a hundred thousand
dollar loan to get a PhD in German polka
history I thought it is stupid I don't
know what is yeah the guaranteed student
loan program is out of control and it's
stupid this is the Dave Ramsey show